einblicke in die welt der tausendstel
sekunde
sichtbar gemacht mit einer der
schnellsten filmkameras der welt und das
sind die macher der bilder die engländer
gewann free und denn quatchi alias rund
130 millionen klicks haben ihre videos
bislang auf youtube erhalten
ich mag es einfach die welt in zeitlupe
zu betrachten sie in unterschiedlichen
geschwindigkeiten zu sehen
in zeitlupe sieht alles gut aus ja
richtig selbst die langweiligsten dinge
eine reihenhaussiedlung in der nähe von
oxford vor mehr als einem jahr hatten
hier die beiden engländer die idee für
ihre videos winfrey arbeitet für eine
firma die zeitlupen kameras vermietet
und immer wenn eine der 100.000 euro
teuren spezial kameras nicht im einsatz
ist
spielen sie damit herum
ich mag es den videos eine persönliche
note zu geben
es gibt auf youtube viele
zeitlupenaufnahmen sie bestehen meist
aus einer einstellung
man weiß nicht wie und warum sie
entstanden sind deshalb machen wir
unsere zeitlupen selbst und präsentieren
sie vor der kamera
das macht sie interessanter und lustiger
70 videos haben die schlomo geist
bereits produziert heute soll die 71
folge entstehen weil zeitlupen kameras
viel licht benötigen müssen sich gegen
frie und dan fritsche beeilen um das
sonnenlicht nutzen zu können
wie immer gibt es kein drehbuch nur ein
grobes konzept über den weiteren verlauf
entscheiden dann die aufnahmen
das trikot spitze das ist schon die
zeitlupe es ist immer noch ziemlich
schnell oder noch sind die beiden nicht
zufrieden das experiment geht weiter um
den vorgang noch weiter zu verlangsamen
machen sie die balance voller
gleichzeitig soll die kamera mehr bilder
aufnehmen genauer 300 mal mehr als eine
normale videokamera
das sind nur zwei ballons geplatzt was
hat also nicht wirklich geklappt
andererseits ist es sehr interessant zu
sehen warum es nicht funktioniert hat
ich habe noch nie gesehen dass eine
kugel nicht in ein ballon einbringt
sondern abprallt aber wir machen noch
einen neuen versuch
denn springt in die luft und schießt
dabei auf einen ballon die tagesmiete
für die spezialkamera beträgt 3000 euro
inklusive kameramann für die slow mo
geist ist es deshalb ein privileg ohne
kostendruck ideen einfach auszuprobieren
etwa in benzin getränkte tennisbälle
anzuzünden und wegzuschießen trotz
vieler versuche nah an der schmerzgrenze
bis auf kleine blessuren ist in slomo
geist bislang nichts passiert
wir bekommen ziemlich viele anfragen von
leuten ob wir nicht diese oder jene
zeitlupen aufnahmen machen können einige
ideen greifen wir dann auf und setzen
sie um
zuerst heißt es aber die eigene ideen
liste abzuarbeiten
und die wächst derzeit schneller als sie
abgedreht werden kann